hey 42 here there have been many
prolific geniuses throughout history
wolfgang amadeus mozart charles dickens
vincent van gaal but legendary film
director
alan smithy differs from these people in
three
important ways firstly he wasn't a
genius
secondly most of his work could be
described as
utter [ __ ] and thirdly he doesn't
actually exist
mind you alan never let his
non-existence
hold him back and when you consider he
directed such
outstanding films as ghost fever
the shrimp on the barbie bloodsucking
pharaohs from pittsburgh
and la zombie de cap rouge it's hard to
believe
he isn't a household name but where did
this
mysterious purveyor of mediocre movies
come from
alan smithy was born in 1969
but through necessity rather than the
birth canal
and with the director's guild of america
acting as midwife you see
alan smithy is simply a fake name
a pseudonym used by members of the dga
when they were so unhappy with a movie
they'd rather burn the negative
themselves
and all of their possessions before
seeing their real name attached to
it but you couldn't just smiffy your
name out of a film willy nilly
oh no first you had to convince a dga
panel
you'd lost creative control of the
project
and even if you did get a yes you
weren't ever allowed to discuss the film
afterwards in other words the first rule
of smithy club
was that you did not talk about smithy
club people had used pseudonyms in the
film industry before of course
in 1947 screenwriter dalton trumbo
was blacklisted in hollywood on
suspicion of being a communist
so he adopted various false names
including robert rich
and felix lutzkendorf to get his work
out into the world
and in 1964 sergio leone
made the legendary spaghetti western a
fistful of dollars
under the name bob robertson thinking it
would be more palatable
to american audiences but
it was with the 1969 film death of a
gunfighter
that the most famous of all hollywood
pseudonyms
first came into being until this point
pseudonyms were against the dga rules
so as to stop producers from forcing
little-known or
unpopular directors to adopt them the
dga were also
great believers in auteur theory which
suggests that
whilst a huge number of people come
together to create a film
the director is the driving creative
force behind it
and should therefore be given full
credit for his work
with death of a gunfighter however
things got a little complicated
lead actor richard whidmark went full
diva and got the original director
robert totten fired
but when filming wrapped new director
don siegel
told a dga panel he didn't feel it was
right for him to be credited as the
director
as the film was mostly totten's work but
tossing himself was understandably upset
at having been
unceremoniously canned from the project
and he didn't want his name attached to
it either
the dga ultimately agreed neither
director's creative vision had been
represented
in the final cut but that left them with
a problem
who were they going to credit as the
director now some have suggested the
name alan smithy with its
two e's was chosen because it's an
anagram
of the alias men but this is
basically an urban legend and with no
real evidence to back it up
the truth sadly is somewhat duller
al smith was the original suggestion
but someone pointed out that picking
such a common name
probably wasn't a great idea which
turned out to be true
because several al smiths were already
working in the film industry at the time
so the al was changed to alan
the smith became smith e
and a non-existent hollywood legend was
born weirdly enough smith e's
first outing as director was critically
acclaimed
which must have been more than slightly
annoying for death of a gunfighters to
anonymous directors he was specifically
singled out for praise with the new york
times writing that alan smithy had
an adroit facility for scanning faces
and extracting
sharp background detail and roger ebbert
for
a long time the preeminent film critic
in the us
saying he admired the way smithy allowed
his story to unfold
naturally but over the years this would
very much be
the exception that proved the rule
watching an allen smithy film
is usually the cinematic equivalent of
getting the tip of your penis caught in
a car door
in other words extremely painful after
all who else but alan smithy would
attempt a sequel to the
alfred hitchcock classic the birds
i mean for hitchcock fans that's akin to
catapulting your own excrement
at the ceiling of the sistine chapel
even actress
tippy hedren who appeared in both films
described
the birds too land's end as absolutely
horrible
and went on to say that it still
embarrassed her decades later
an imdb rating of 2.9 suggests
that embarrassment was entirely
warranted too
in some cases directors have smiffied
their movies
many years after the original release
due to them being
well and truly mangled for television
when it came to the tv version of david
lynch's june for example
he not only insisted on an alan smithy
directing credit
but also changed his screenwriting
credit to
judas booth a combination of judas
iscariot
and john wilkes booth if your
screenwriting pseudonym
is a mixture of the man who betrayed
christ and the man who shot abraham
lincoln
it's probably fair to say you're not a
big fan of the script
director michael mann has had to give
his credit to god smiffying
on more than one occasion not least when
nbc wanted to re-cut his three-hour epic
heat back in 1999 man told variety
that so much was cut out of the movie it
completely destroyed the narrative
and he went on to describe the edit as
piss-poor management of an asset
they paid a lot of money for another
serial credit
murderer is martin brest who felt the
same way about the in-flight versions of
his films
meet joe black and scent of a woman as
the rest of us feel about in-flight
meals
needless to say he wasted no time in
smithying the living daylights out of
them
not all attempts by directors to smithy
themselves out of their films have been
successful however
director tony k did his best to disown
american history x after cast members
made changes to the script
and the studio rejected his incredibly
bleak finale
kay left in a huff and then tried to
alan his way out of a credit
which was rejected by the dga so
he tried again with another alias humpty
dumpty
surprisingly that didn't work either so
he sued the dga for 200 million dollars
and alienated himself from everyone in
hollywood in the process
he's also reported to have engaged in
some
pretty bizarre behavior during this time
like
turning up to a meeting with the film
studio accompanied by
a rabbi a tibetan monk and a priest
which sounds like the start of an
inappropriate joke your uncle tells you
when he's had too much to drink
but apparently kaye was deadly serious
feeling he needed the help of god to get
his point across
i suppose that's hollywood for you you
never have that kind of trouble running
a youtube channel
possibly one of the most ironic uses of
hollywood's favorite pseudonym
was in 1997's an allen smithy film
burn hollywood burn a mockumentary with
eric idle playing a director
named alan smithy who tries to disown
his big budget action film starring
sylvester stallone
whoopi goldberg and jackie chan needless
to say
he can't alan smithy himself out of the
credits
because that's already his name so he's
forced to steal the film
and go on the run which all sounds
confusing enough as
it is before you factor in what happened
after production
you see director arthur hiller like many
directors before him
complained to the dga that he'd been
kept out of the editing process
and should therefore be able to abstain
from a credit on the film all of which
means that a film about alan smithy
called an alan smithy film burn
hollywood burn
ended up being directed by alan smiffy
himself you just couldn't make it up
which is pretty much how hiller felt to
add insult to injury the film was a
massive failure
which probably shouldn't come as too
much of a surprise considering the
entire plot was based on an obscure
piece of hollywood culture
the vast majority of the population has
never even heard of
it grows just under sixty thousand
dollars worldwide
despite having an estimated budget of 10
million and was absolutely crucified by
the critics
with a weird sense of coming full circle
roger ebbert
who'd written such a positive review of
death of a gunfighter
back in 1969 the film which gave birth
to alan smithy
gave this one a score of zero stars
it has a rotten tomatoes rating of eight
percent positive
and their critical consensus calls it a
witless hollywood satire whose hammy
obvious jokes
are neither funny nor insightful of the
movie business
pretty damning but then i suppose it's
their job to be critical
when your lead actor saying a similar
thing however
then it's probably not a great sign even
when he was busy promoting the film eric
heidel regularly came out with the
phrase
this is rather dreadful if it was
possible for actors to smiffy themselves
out of a film
you can bet idol would have done so even
if he was portraying a character called
alan smithy
burn hollywood byrne went on to win four
razzies
or golden raspberry awards for worst
picture
worst screenplay worst new star and
worst supporting actor all of which went
to joe estojaras
who both starred in and produced a film
sylvester stallone was also nominated in
the worst supporting actor category that
year
which is particularly ironic when you
consider
he was playing himself you know your
acting career is in trouble
when you can't even portray yourself
convincingly
esther juarez also won the stinker award
for
worst on-screen hairstyle and the film
was nominated for
another stinker in the category of most
painfully unfunny comedy
so yeah it's fair to say it wasn't a
great piece of work
but perhaps its most damning legacy of
all was that even alan smithy couldn't
get work
afterwards the negativity surrounding
the film had brought so much attention
to the pseudonym
it could no longer be used at all
filmmakers have used a variety of other
pseudonyms over the years
but for comedy value none are quite as
good as screenwriter robert townes
after his passion project 1984's
greystroke the legend of tarzan lord of
the apes
was destroyed by studio interference he
removed his writing credit and replaced
it with ph
vazak which might sound exotic but was
actually the name of his pet sheepdog
this not only highlighted the fact that
more dogs should have surnames
but also resulted in an academy award
nomination for the screenplay
making ph vazak the world's first
and only canine to be considered for an
oscar
good boy animal pseudonyms seem to be
popular within the screenwriting
community
because fantasy writer harlan ellison
occasionally used the name
chord wayne a bird when his work was
mangled by producers
fellow writer stephen king thought this
was ellison's subtle way
of flipping studio xx the bird
here in the uk we briefly had our own
version of alan smithy
david agnew a name that was invented to
overcome a very british problem
bureaucracy this pseudonym was used in
the bbc during the 70s if freelance
writers were unable to incorporate
changes requested by a show's producer
at the very last minute when that
happened members of the production staff
who weren't allowed to take screen
credits without a long drawn-out appeals
process
would be asked to perform a rewrite
under agnew's name
one notable example is the 1979 doctor
who episode
city of death not least because it was
co-written by hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy author douglas adams
if you aren't familiar with adam's work
i encourage you to go and check it out
that guy really does know a thing or two
about life
the universe and everything anyway david
agnew has since become a familiar name
in doctor who fandom
occasionally popping up in other
episodes and books not to mention the
mockumentary
the elusive david agnew which by the way
was directed by some guy called alan
smithy back on the other side of the
atlantic
allen has also enjoyed a thriving career
outside of motion pictures
he directed two episodes of macgyver a
few segments of tiny toon adventures
and a couple of episodes of the cosby
show although to be fair it isn't only
disgruntled directors who want to
distance themselves from bill cosby
these days
smithy's also written several comics for
dc and marvel
and has even dipped his toe into the
world of gaming the 1993 nintendo game
equinox credits alan smithy as director
marine sharpshooter 4 has him as art
director
and in a weird twist allen showed up as
the director of metal gear solid 4 in a
teaser trailer
before being replaced by hideo kojima at
launch
is it possible that alan smithy
requested his name to be removed from
the project
maybe he didn't want such a critically
acclaimed game ruining his
hard-fought reputation as one of the
worst directors ever to have lived
or ever to have not lived in this case
like many famous directors before him
alan's also worked on quite a few music
videos in his time
there was whitney houston's i will
always love you kiss the rain by billy
myers
waiting for tonight by jennifer lopez
maria by blondie
and lose my breath by destiny's child
but despite his glittering career and
music promos
there doesn't seem to be an official
alan smithy for the musicians themselves
which is a shame because some of them
seem pretty keen to disown their most
famous works
for example radiohead have long since
grown tired of their signature
song creep going so far as to pull it
from their live set for seven years
led zeppelin's robert plant once pledged
ten thousand dollars to a radio station
if they agreed to never play stairway to
heaven again
and in 2008 madonna publicly stated
she wouldn't sing like a virgin or
holiday
ever again unless somebody paid her 30
million dollars
mind you she was singing them eight
years later on her 2016 tour
so i guess someone put up the cash so
much for artistic integrity a madge
after some 30 years at the top or bottom
alan smithy's career was officially over
by the year 2000
following director walter hill's
attempts to get his film
supernova off the ground hill's budget
was not only cut by the studio halfway
through production
but they also decided to preview the
movie before any of the special effects
had been added
not a great choice for a sci-fi film
anyway hill soon left the project but
due to the backlash from burn hollywood
byrne
his name wasn't replaced by alan smithy
but by thomas lee a new name the dga
were trying
out the great alan smiffy
was officially dead but despite the
significant handicap
of being deceased alan still pops up
every now and then
albeit with various creative tweaks the
duo
of alan and alana smithy wrote the
screenplay for the film hidden 3d
and in 2010 a dutch female version of
alan
ellen smith most likely to meet their
imaginary employees diversity quota
directed the film eep and then in 2018
defying all medical explanations
the late helen smithy himself directed
the horror movie
the night watchers along with several
episodes of the french tv series
tomorrow is ours
for a dead guy he's been surprisingly
busy but hey
alan's never let a little thing like not
existing get in the way of his work
and i think it's about time hollywood
gave him some recognition
after all who else can you think of with
such an extensive imdb listing
let me leave you of this thought a
screenwriter charlie kaufman was
nominated for an oscar for the 2002 film
adaptation
along with his late twin brother donald
the weird thing however was that donald
hadn't
died in fact he'd never lived
kaufman just invented him to add depth
to his multi-dimensional plot
and decided to give him a screenwriting
credit
so if charlie's non-existent donald can
be nominated for an oscar
then why can't our non-existent alan he
doesn't have to win of course
and he probably won't because he's
directed some of the worst films in
history
but hey it's the thought that counts
thanks for watching
you can now buy my new book stick a flag
in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below
thank you